[Musica]
ma il grido
genera ascolto
spesso ci sentiamo frammentati
rotti
ognuno di noi è coinvolto in una corsa
quotidiana tra mille faccende
preoccupazioni
e possiamo dirlo siamo immersi in così
tanta difficoltà che non riusciamo più a
vedere le cose semplici non riusciamo
più a fermarci per capire cosa sia
veramente essenziale nella nostra vita
Ma davvero non riusciamo
O forse non vogliamo
ho sempre sentito dentro di me una
grande inquietudine che ovviamente mi ha
portato nella vita compiere certe scelte
piuttosto che altre
quante volte capita di sentirsi fuori
posto di sentirsi sbagliati inadeguati
o semplicemente quante volte la società
in cui viviamo ci spinge a sentirci così
poco sincronizzati con chi dovremmo
essere
Facendoci sentire quindi disallineati
Ma qual è davvero il nostro centro
e soprattutto da dove proviene questo
grido che ogni tanto sentiamo
per capire da dove questa inquietudine
era originata ho sentito il bisogno di
conoscere di guardare di muovermi ma
anche di fermarmi e osservarmi stando
ferma perché per osservarsi bisogna
fermarsi non possiamo stare sul balcone
allo stesso tempo guardarci passare
E così ho provato in qualche modo a dare
una forma questa inquietudine
a darle un nome
per fare questo ho sentito la necessità
di abbandonare quelle che erano le mie
certezze lasciare momentaneamente la mia
casa i miei amici la mia famiglia per
affacciarmi ad un contesto completamente
differente
e sono partita per l'Africa con un
desiderio tale di vedere vivere che mi
ha permesso di camminare in totale
spontaneità
anche nei momenti più difficili e
impensabili forse nella mente di una
ragazzina di 17 anni di Cesena
in Africa il mio primo incontro è stato
con Mistura un bimbo di circa 4 anni
alto più o meno così
che mi aspettava ogni giorno davanti
alla porta pronto per iniziare la
giornata
misura in qualche modo mi ha donato quei
brividi nel cuore che ti fanno sentire
vera
viva e utile
ed è stato il primo bambino ad invitarmi
nella sua casa
o meglio nella sua capanna
mi accompagnavo ovunque al fiume a
prendere l'acqua in buche scavate nel
terreno
e si preoccupava di me e di ogni mio
singolo gesto
tra noi per relazionarci sono bastate
poche parole
perché in realtà tutto il resto in
qualche modo è venuto da sé
Infatti Ecco che
l'incontro o meglio lo scontro tra due
esseri diversi quello scontro che magari
inizialmente provoca
confusione disagio per me non è stato
altro che una sfida
capace di rivelarmi qualcosa di
impensabile e mai visto prima
attraverso quella che possiamo chiamare
come cultura del dono il mio atto non
era più privatizzazione di energie ma
una sensazione tale da riempirmi di
gioia
e il mio tempo non era nemmeno
monetizzazione Ma possiamo chiamarla
cittadinanza attiva
Ecco che una volta tornata a casa Non ho
fatto altro che sperimentare
sono andata a Reggio Calabria in una
casa di accoglienza per minori stranieri
non accompagnati lì ho conosciuto volti
e ho imparato ad ascoltare in punta di
piedi che cosa volesse dire per un
ragazzo della mia stessa età lasciare la
propria casa la propria famiglia per
vivere a metà
Tra il passato e il presente
sospeso tra la vita che si aspettava si
immaginava e la vita che per qualche
motivo gli tocca
e fare un viaggio infinito in condizioni
per noi inimmaginabili per rimanere ora
fermo in una casa di accoglienza in
attesa di realizzare i propri sogni
e nonostante questo
riconoscere il loro un senso di
gratitudine
Innanzitutto verso un origine che non è
nostra perché non ci siamo fatti da soli
e verso un sogno che alla fine gli ha
permesso di andare avanti
almeno un pochettino
parlando tra noi siamo sinceri quante
volte ci siamo detti mi piacerebbe
essere più alto o mi piacerebbe essere
più ricco oppure semplicemente io Se
solo avessi 5 anni in più avrei già
finito l'università
sì
bene È qui che la mia irrecutezza è
andata a sbattere è stata messa in
dubbio perché Certo io di sogni ne avevo
pochi veri
ma possibilità tante
e la realtà dei fatti mi ha confermato e
mi conferma tuttora che certamente loro
vivono una vita più dura della nostra è
inutile negarlo Ma la speranza dei loro
sogni
è molto più potente rispetto al nostro
desiderio di vita che
ogni tanto perdiamo
Eppure dopo aver conosciuto una
piccolissima parte di mondo mi sono resa
conto che non conoscevo nemmeno me
stessa e che quindi dovevo scendere un
po' di più nelle mie profondità dovevo
conoscermi di nuovo e questo mi è stato
possibile grazie ad una meravigliosa
esperienza condotta durante il quarto
anno a Rondine in un piccolo borgo nel
cuore della Toscana dove di conflitti se
ne affrontano davvero tanti a partire da
quelli interiore fino a quello tra due
nemici di guerra tra due ragazzi
provenienti dai Paesi in conflitto o
post conflitto che scelgono di
conoscersi di stare insieme relazionarsi
per decostruire quella che è l'idea di
nemico
e se Rondine riescono a fare questo
servono due ragazzi
riescono a riconoscersi vulnerabili Che
cosa possiamo fare noi
il mio percorso Rondine mi ha aiutata a
capire che amare è molto bello ma è
altrettanto bello anche farsi amare
chiedendo aiuto chiedendo conforto
qualora ce ne fosse bisogno
e ho imparato a riconoscere dove magari
mi sento stretta e dove posso sentirmi
più leggera e fluida
e se ora vi starete chiedendo se sono
riuscita ad abbandonare quella che era
la mia inquietudine se sono riuscita ad
alleggerire forse un po' il mio cuore
Beh devo ammettere che non ci sono
riuscita Anzi è proprio ancora qui con
me però spero mi accompagnerà per tutto
il percorso perché sto imparando a
conviverci sto imparando a plasmarla
attraverso esperienze che si sono
esperienze che ti rompono ma esperienza
attraverso cui il dolore non ti uccide
ti apre
non serve essere ricchi per essere grati
le cose belle sfuggono ti scappano di
mano a volte non possiamo neanche fare
troppi ragionamenti a girarci troppo
intorno a volte è necessario lasciare
andare per trovare un senso anche
piccolo
ma vero
c'è sempre qualcosa da fare ci sarà
sempre qualcuno che avrà bisogno di me
di te o magari di tutti noi messi
insieme
forse una cosa che facciamo fatica a
credere è che alle volte siamo anche
abbastanza tutto
Il grido è la nostra opportunità di
metterci al muro
di spogliarci di quelle che sono le
nostre sicurezze di abbattere quelle che
sono le barriere che in qualche modo ci
separano
di decostruire l'idea di nemico e
finalmente incontrare
l'uomo che grida
Grazie
[Applauso]